This is Roman Mars. I'm in beautiful San Francisco, California. Recently, Roman headed across the bay from Oakland to San Francisco. He is not in the city very much, only a couple times a month. But if I'm here during the daytime and I have a little bit of time, I very often go to Tony's slice house in North Beach and get a slice of pizza and soda and a paper cup. Roman took his pizza and he started walking and when he was done eating he looked around for a trash can. There's no trash can where I'm sitting right now.
我是罗曼·马尔斯。我在美丽的加利福尼亚州旧金山。最近，罗曼从奥克兰跨越海湾来到了旧金山。他并不经常来这个城市，一个月也就来个两三次。但如果我白天来到这里，而且有一点时间，我经常会去北海滩托尼切片比萨店，买一片比萨、一杯苏打水和一个纸杯。罗曼拿着他的比萨开始散步，当他吃完时，他环顾四周寻找垃圾桶。我现在坐的地方附近就没有垃圾桶。
I don't know if there's one in the next block, but I kind of expect a trash can every major intersection. Because that's where people end up standing while they wait to cross the street and they might have something to throw away. It makes sense. But like he said, no trash cans in sight. And it got me thinking,
我不知道下一个街区有没有，但我有点期望每个主要路口都有一个垃圾桶。因为那是人们等红绿灯过马路时站立的地方，他们可能正好有东西要扔。这很合情合理。但就像他说的，方圆百里看不到一个垃圾桶。这让我开始思考，
who determines how frequent there should be a trash can? And like, who determines the placement? Are they placed, like, strategically? Is there an algorithm or a formula for these things? Because when I see the sort of dirt of trash cans in the city, and I'm walking around with my, you know, food waste, I think, well, this is why the city is so dark. Like, it has a lot of litter.
到底是谁决定应该有多密集的垃圾桶？比如，是谁决定它们的放置地点的？它们的放置是有策略的吗？这些事情背后有没有什么算法或公式？因为当我看到这座城市里垃圾桶的这种零乱状况，而我手里又拿着吃剩的东西到处走时，我想，难怪这个城市这么脏。比如说，这里有很多垃圾。
I don't mean to sound like Tucker Carlson. Civilization itself is coming apart in San Francisco, right there in broad daylight, on the city's sidewalks, which are littered with junkies and feces and dirty needles. But some parts of San Francisco can sometimes be a little bit dirty. San Francisco is fantastic, and anyone who fearmongers about it doesn't know it, and they should just fuck off. But it does have litter. And I think, well, maybe it has so much litter because it has so few trash cans. And so I really want to figure this out. Like, who determines the trash cans?
我可不想听起来像塔克·卡尔森那样。旧金山的文明本身正在瓦解，就在光天化日之下的城市人行道上，上面到处都是瘾君子、粪便和脏针头。但旧金山的某些地方有时确实可能会有点脏。旧金山棒极了，任何贩卖对它的恐惧的人根本不了解它，他们应该滚蛋。不过这里确实有垃圾。我想，也许这里有这么多垃圾是因为这里的垃圾桶太少了。所以我真的很想弄清楚这一点。比如，到底是谁在决定垃圾桶的事？
Even how they get picked up, how are they maintained, how are they designed? I just really want to figure this out. Or I want this to be figured out for me. I'm Delaney Hall and this is service request from 99% Invisible and Campside Media. Each week, we take your burning questions about infrastructure and we investigate. Today, our service request comes from my boss, Roman Mars, and it gets into seemingly small stuff like the mechanics of trash can design and placement and big stuff like city procurement processes and the politics of trash. We're looking at how the trash cans in San Francisco actually work. We have about 3,000 locations in San Francisco.
甚至包括它们是怎么被收走的，它们是怎么维护的，它们是怎么设计的？我真的只想把这些搞清楚。或者我希望有人能为我把这些搞清楚。我是德莱尼·霍尔，这是来自《99%无形》和Campside传媒的服务请求。每周，我们都会探讨你们关于基础设施的迫切疑问并进行调查。今天，我们的服务请求来自我的老板罗曼·马尔斯，它涉及一些看似微小的事情，比如垃圾桶设计的机制和摆放位置，以及一些大事，比如城市的采购流程和垃圾政治。我们来看看旧金山的垃圾桶到底是如何运作的。我们在旧金山大约有3000个点位。
San Francisco with garbage cans. It's actually one of the most garbage cans for a city are size. Today our guide is Rachel Gordon, the director of policy and communications at San Francisco Public Works. Public Works is one of the city's largest departments. It's responsible for designing and building streets, planting trees, cleaning up graffiti, and keeping the city's buildings running. They also install and maintain the city's public trash cans. And we focus where the garbage. cans are going to be. So we put them near transit stops, commercial corridors, near schools, hospitals, health centers, places where there are going to be a lot of people. You'll see fewer garbage cans in purely residential areas, although we do get requests if it's on a kind of a common
旧金山的垃圾桶。按城市的规模来看，其实这里的垃圾桶数量相当多。今天的向导是雷切尔·戈登，她是旧金山公共工程局的政策与传播总监。公共工程局是该市最大的部门之一。它负责设计和建设街道、种树、清理涂鸦，以及维持城市建筑的运转。他们还负责安装和维护城市的公共垃圾桶。我们会关注垃圾桶应该放在哪里。所以我们把它们放在公交站附近、商业走廊、学校、医院、健康中心附近，也就是人流量大的地方。在纯住宅区你会看到较少的垃圾桶，尽管如果是在某种常见的遛狗路线上，我们也会接到请求。
dog walking route. We will try to get garbage cans there so people can dispose of their dog waste. In addition to focusing on the busiest areas of the city and the neighborhoods with lots of dogs, The department also fields requests from 311 and from the district board of supervisors, which is San Francisco's version of a city council. If they hear from constituents that they want garbage cans in certain areas, we will go and we do a couple of things. We look to see, has there been a garbage can there before? Has it been removed for some reason? So we track what kind of complaints there have been. If they've been taken out before or sometimes they go back and forth multiple times, then we will not put, we will not put a garbage. can back in that location.
我们会尽量在那里设置垃圾桶，以便人们处理狗的粪便。除了关注城市中最繁忙的区域和有很多狗的社区外，该部门还会处理来自311以及区监事会的请求，后者相当于旧金山的市议会。如果他们从选民那里听说希望在某些区域设立垃圾桶，我们就会去进行调查，通常会做以下几件事。我们去看看，以前那里有过垃圾桶吗？是不是出于某种原因被移走了？所以我们会追踪之前有过什么样的投诉。如果它们以前被撤走过，或者有时它们被反复撤走又安装多次，那么我们就不会把垃圾桶再放回那个位置。
This was my first hint that the way trash cans work in San Francisco is not always straightforward. Sometimes trash cans get placed and then pulled and then placed again. Rachel says this can go back and forth a few times, and it's clear there are fights happening about trash cans. It turns out that one way the Department of Public Works deals with that is to run pilot programs, trying to gather actual data about what happens when trash cans go in somewhere new. That's what happened back in 2017, when the city ran a pilot that spiraled into a nearly 10-year odyssey to try and tackle the issue of litter in San Francisco.
这是给我的第一个暗示，即旧金山的垃圾桶运作方式并不总是那么简单。有时垃圾桶装上了又被撤走，然后又装上。雷切尔说这种情况可以反复好几次，很显然，关于垃圾桶的争夺一直在上演。事实证明，公共工程局应对这种情况的方法之一就是开展试点项目，试图收集关于垃圾桶出现在新地方时会发生什么的实际数据。这就是2017年发生的事情，当时该市开展了一个试点项目，演变成了一场长达近十年的漫长探索，试图解决旧金山的垃圾清理问题。
In the process, it revealed all kinds of weird and counterintuitive stuff about how garbage works in the city. The pilot started in one neighborhood, running about 30 blocks. through the Mission District. It's a very high-trafficked, dense commercial corridor with businesses' ground floor apartments up top. We put a garbage can on every corner, so four garbage cans at each intersection, and then on most of the blocks,
在这个过程中，它揭示了关于这个城市垃圾处理方式的各种诡异且反直觉的事情。试点从一个社区开始，覆盖了米慎区大约30个街区。这是一个客流量非常大、人口密集的商业走廊，底层是商铺，上面是公寓。我们在每个街角都放置了一个垃圾桶，也就是每个路口有四个垃圾桶，然后在大多数街区，
we put other garbage cans mid-block. We wanted to see, if we have all these garbage cans, will there be less litter on the street? It was a lot of litter on that block, a lot of bus stops, transit stops there, There were some pretty good reasons to think that more trash cans might mean less trash. For one thing, it just seems kind of intuitive. But also, there's this often repeated story in the world of trash management about Walt Disney.
我们在街区中间放置了其他垃圾桶。我们想看看，如果我们有这么多垃圾桶，街上的垃圾会不会变少？那个街区有很多垃圾，有很多公交车站、公交枢纽，有充分的理由认为更多的垃圾桶可能意味着更少的垃圾。一方面，这看起来似乎很直观。但另一方面，在垃圾管理界流传着一个关于华特·迪士尼的故事。
He supposedly spent time watching visitors at Disneyland, and he observed that people would carry trash for about 30 steps before dropping it. And so, he placed trash cans every 30 steps. Now, it is not really clear if this story is true, but the basic principle has been backed up by research. Studies show that when trash cans are visible, closely spaced, and well-maintained, people typically throw less litter on the ground. But that is not really what Public Works found with their pilot in the Mission District. We noticed that it really did not make that much of a difference at the end of the day. In some spots there was less litter. In some spots, the litter was just the same.
据说他曾花时间观察迪士尼乐园的游客，他发现人们在扔掉垃圾之前，大约会拿着垃圾走30步。于是，他每隔30步就放置一个垃圾桶。现在，这个故事是否真实并不十分清楚，但其基本原理已经得到了研究的支持。研究表明，当垃圾桶清晰可见、摆放密集且维护良好时，人们通常会向地面乱扔更少的垃圾。但这并不是公共工程局在米慎区试点时真正发现的情况。我们注意到，到头来这其实并没有产生多大影响。在某些地方垃圾变少了。在某些地方，垃圾和以前一样多。
In some spots, it was more. Several times I'd be out on the block watching or out on the street watching, and I literally see people standing at a bus. Their bus comes. There'd be a garbage can five to ten feet from them, and they dump their candy bar wrapper on the ground. I'm picturing you sort of out there standing subtly off to the side, watching people at a bus stop, seeing someone drop a candy wrap.
在某些地方，垃圾反而更多了。有好几次我在街区或街上巡视时，亲眼看到人们站在公交车站旁。他们的公交车来了。离他们五到十英尺远的地方就有一个垃圾桶，而他们却把糖果包装纸直接扔在地上。我想象着你当时站在一旁，不引人注目地观察着公交车站的人们，看到有人扔了一张糖果包装纸。
around the ground. It's reminding me of my children. I just watch them open a snack and then just leave the trash on our floor. What is the psychology behind that where you're like, you know the bin is right there? You know, what do you think is going on? That's a good question. I mean, one of the things we've discussed a lot in public works is what would happen if we did not pick up the garbage. We don't want our city to look dirty and messy. So we will have street cleaners. We will go and pick up the trash. So in a way, it's like a maid service at a hotel, right? You don't make your bed. Someone else comes in and makes it. You throw down your candy wrapper on the street of San Francisco. Somebody's going to come by and eventually pick it up.
掉在地上。这让我想起了我的孩子们。我看着他们打开一份零食，然后就把垃圾直接丢在地板上。这背后的心理是什么？你知道垃圾桶就在那里，却还要这样做。你觉得是怎么回事？这真是个好问题。我的意思是，我们在公共工程局经常讨论的事情之一是，如果我们不收垃圾会发生什么。我们不希望我们的城市看起来又脏又乱。所以我们会安排街道清洁工。我们会去清理垃圾。所以从某种程度上说，这就像酒店的客房服务，对吧？你不叠被子。别人会进来帮你叠。你把糖果包装纸扔在旧金山的街道上。总会有人顺路过来把它捡起来。
So it's not, not everyone is a slob and a litter bug in San Francisco at all. But I have seen people pull into a parking space with very nice cars and they dump out their ashtray and the coffee cup and they put it on the curb and take it out of their car. They don't want their car messy. They'll put it out on the sidewalk and then someone from Public Works or another nonprofit will come come by and clean it up. Right. It strikes me that there's something almost a little paradoxical about what you learned from that pilot, which is that more trash cans does not necessarily mean cleaner streets. Why do you think that? is. Because it's, again, it's about behavior. So trash cans really are a convenience for people. I think
所以并不是说旧金山的所有人都懒惰又爱乱扔垃圾。但我确实看到过人们开着非常漂亮的豪车停进停车位，然后他们清理烟灰缸和咖啡杯，把它们放在路缘上，从车里拿出来。他们不想让车里变脏。他们会把垃圾放在人行道上，然后公共工程局或其他非营利组织的人就会过来清理干净。没错。我觉得你从那个试点中学到的东西有点自相矛盾，那就是更多的垃圾桶并不一定意味着更干净的街道。你觉得这是为什么？因为这又回到了行为本身。所以垃圾桶对人们来说真的只是一种便利。我认为
it's great if someone has that, that they've finished something, eating something, reading something in newspaper or whatever. They don't want to carry it back home with them. They want the convenience of dumping it into a public trash can. Something I learned in this conversation with Rachel is that there is not one universal way that trash and trash cans work. It's more like there are different cultures of trash. One place that Rachel mentioned is Japan. And even in very big and busy cities like Tokyo, there are very few public trash cans on the street. This actually goes back to 1995 when cult members released sarin gas in the Tokyo subway, killing more than a dozen people. The attack led the country to remove trash cans from public places as a precautionary measure so that no one could hide anything in the bins.
如果有人吃完东西、读完报纸或其他什么东西后能有这样的便利，那就太好了。他们不想把垃圾带回家。他们想要将其扔进公共垃圾桶的便利。我在与雷切尔的这次交谈中学到的一点是，垃圾和垃圾桶的运作方式并没有一种普遍的标准。更确切地说，这里存在着不同的垃圾文化。雷切尔提到的一个地方是日本。即使在东京这样非常大且繁忙的城市，街头也很少有公共垃圾桶。这其实可以追溯到1995年，当时邪教成员在东京地铁释放沙林毒气，导致十几人死亡。这起袭击事件促使该国作为预防措施从公共场所撤走了垃圾桶，这样就不会有人把任何东西藏在垃圾桶里了。
The trash cans never really came back, but somehow Japan remains spotless. clean. There's now a cultural understanding that you keep your trash and then throw it away when you get home. And even within the U.S., there seem to be different trash cultures here, too. Unlike San Francisco, there are places where the more trash cans equals less litter equation seems to be true. I've gone to, you know, New York, Philadelphia, Baltimore, Chicago, Seattle, Portland. We have people going all over and they go like, how come you can have a trash can in these? cities, but you can't have one in San Francisco. We don't have that magic answer of why it's happening, but we do know it's happening. Rachel may not have a definitive answer about what's going on in San Francisco, but she does have some theories. For one, the city has a higher than average unhoused population. And sometimes people sort through public trash cans for valuable recyclables and then leave trash scattered on the ground. They're looking for things to recycle.
垃圾桶再也没有真正回来过，但不知何故，日本依然一尘不染。现在大家有一种文化共识，即把垃圾随身携带，回家后再扔掉。即便在美国国内，似乎也存在着不同的垃圾文化。与旧金山不同，有些地方“垃圾桶越多等于垃圾越少”这个等式似乎是成立的。我去过纽约、费城、巴尔的摩、芝加哥、西雅图、波特兰。我们派人去过各地，他们会问：为什么这些城市可以有垃圾桶，而旧金山却不能？我们没有那种万能的答案来解释为什么会这样，但我们知道它确实正在发生。雷切尔可能对旧金山发生的事情没有一个确定的答案，但她确实有一些推测。首先，该市的无家可归者人口比例高于平均水平。有时人们会翻找公共垃圾桶寻找有价值的可回收物，然后把垃圾散落在地上。他们在寻找可以回收的东西。
Then they bust them open and to pull things out. Then there's illegal dumping, which is a huge part of the equation. About 18,000 tons of trash get dumped on San Francisco streets every year. This is stuff like mattresses, furniture, construction debris, and bags of garbage. Here's another kind of dump site that we see a lot here in Bayview. It looks like someone kind of put it near a garbage can and then left it on the sidewalk on the street. Public Works actually has a team of investigators who go out and rip open trash bags looking for addresses and shipping labels to figure out who's responsible. So that will take a DPW crew, you know, a while to pick that up.
然后他们把垃圾桶砸开把东西掏出来。接着就是非法倾倒，这是整个问题中很大的一部分。每年大约有18000吨垃圾被倾倒在旧金山的街道上。这些东西包括床垫、家具、建筑垃圾和一袋袋的垃圾。这是我们在湾景区经常看到的另一种垃圾倾倒点。看起来就像有人把它放在垃圾桶附近，然后就留在了街上的人行道上。公共工程局其实有一支调查员队伍，他们会出动并撕开垃圾袋，寻找地址和快递面单，以弄清楚是谁干的。所以公共工程局的工作人员需要花点时间去清理这些垃圾。
And, you know, the question is, what's in there? You know, that building materials, is it, you know, is it toxic? On top of that, there have been complaints about a scandal-plagued company called RECology, which the city has hired to empty the truck. trash cans on a daily basis. Some people complain that Rekology does not empty them enough. When we walk around the trash cans, we see like overflowing with pizza boxes large and small and they're everywhere. Anyway, for whatever reason, there's litter. And when it comes to littering, studies show that people take their cues from their environment. When a space looks clean,
而且，你知道，问题是，里面有什么？你知道，那是建筑材料吗，是，你知道，有毒吗？最重要的是，人们对一家丑闻缠身的名为Recology的公司抱怨不断，该公司被市政府雇佣来每天清空垃圾桶。有些人抱怨Recology清理得不够勤快。当我们走过垃圾桶时，我们看到里面塞满了大大小小的比萨盒，到处都是。总之，不管出于什么原因，到处都有垃圾。当谈到乱扔垃圾时，研究表明人们会从他们的环境中寻找暗示。当一个空间看起来很干净时，
they tend to keep it clean. But when it's already dirty, they feel more comfortable adding to the And so in a place like San Francisco, it can become a self-reinforcing cycle of trash leading to more trash. Which brings us back to the trash can pilot in the Mission District. Adding cans didn't really seem to help with the litter, and so Public Works decided to run a different experiment. They wondered, what if instead of putting out more trash cans, they redesigned them? Their old models, known as the Renaissance cans, had been on the streets since 1993, and they were reaching the end of their natural lifespan. So it was time for new cans. And maybe the city could find a new design that worked better, was less vulnerable to trash picking, and maybe most importantly, was sturdier.
他们往往会保持它的清洁。但当它已经很脏时，他们就会更心安理得地往上面添乱。所以在像旧金山这样的地方，它可能会变成一个垃圾导致更多垃圾的自我强化循环。这就把我们带回了米慎区的垃圾桶试点项目。增加垃圾桶似乎并没有真正有助于减少垃圾，因此公共工程局决定改用另一种实验。他们想知道，如果不是摆放更多垃圾桶，而是重新设计它们会怎么样？他们旧型号的垃圾桶被称为“文艺复兴”垃圾桶，自1993年以来就一直在街头服役，而且它们已经接近自然寿命的尽头。所以是时候换新垃圾桶了。也许这座城市能找到一种设计更好、更能防范拾荒，而且也许最重要的是，更加坚固的新设计。
Because here's another thing that happens in San Francisco. People attack the trash cans. If there's any way a trash can be vandalized, people will find a way to do it. It's everything of breaking the doors of the trash cans, graffiti vandalism. People will break things to try to get into the trash cans. So that's a big issue. When we put a trash can out, people say we want a trash can on the corner. It's not long before someone says, take this trash can off the corner.
因为旧金山还会发生另一件事。人们会攻击垃圾桶。如果有什么方法可以破坏垃圾桶，人们总能找到办法做到这一点。从砸坏垃圾桶的门，到涂鸦破坏，应有尽有。人们会破坏各种东西以试图进入垃圾桶内部。所以这是一个大问题。当我们摆出一个垃圾桶时，人们会说我们在街角想要一个垃圾桶。没过多久，就会有人说把街角的这个垃圾桶拿走吧。
It's causing more of a nuisance. We have some trash cans in the city that are 600 pounds or cement trash cans. and people will tip them over. I'll take a bunch of people to do that, but to pull them back up, we need to bring a crane out to do that. So it really has been a fascinating, let's just say, a policy adventure in San Francisco.
它造成了更多麻烦。我们在市内有一些重达600磅的混凝土垃圾桶，而人们会把它们推翻。要把它们推翻需要好几个人，但要把它们拉起来，我们需要开着吊车来完成。所以这确实是一场引人入胜的、不妨这么说的政策冒险。
The policy adventure continues when we come back. So after this experiment in the Mission District, you pivoted from adding cans to actually redesigning them. What led to that decision? We didn't see what the existing cans could do in terms of reducing litter on the streets. We wanted to see, could we find a can or come up with a can design to make it more difficult, again, for people to rummage through them, if they're going to get graffiti tagged, is it easier to clean? Do they have good locking mechanisms? So we went out for a contest.
当我们回来时，政策冒险将继续。所以在米慎区的这次实验之后，你们从增加垃圾桶转向了重新设计垃圾桶。是什么促成了这个决定？我们在减少街头垃圾方面没有看到现有垃圾桶能发挥什么作用。我们想看看，我们能否找到一个垃圾桶或设计出一种垃圾桶，再次加大人们翻找垃圾的难度，如果它们被喷上涂鸦，是否更容易清洗？它们是否有良好的锁定机制？所以我们发起了一场竞赛。
We looked at three designs that we prototyped. We also took existing garbage cans that we could buy from off-frey. the shelf models. We put them out to the test with the public. The three custom trash can designs included the salt and pepper, which had a distinctive two-tiered shape with one section for bottles and cans and another for trash. Then there was the slim silhouette, a narrow can with stainless steel bars on the outside to discourage graffiti. And finally, there was the soft square, which featured curved panels and a foot pedal to open it. The city also picked three.
我们考察了三种做成原型的设计。我们还挑选了可以从市面上直接买到的现成垃圾桶型号。我们把它们拿出来接受公众的测试。这三种定制的垃圾桶设计包括“盐与胡椒”，它具有独特的分层形状，一部分用于存放瓶子和罐头，另一部分用于存放垃圾。还有“苗条剪影”，这是一个窄型垃圾桶，外部带有不锈钢栏杆以防止涂鸦。最后是“柔和方块”，它具有弧形面板和用于打开它的脚踏板。该市还挑选了三个。
off-the-shelf garbage can models to include in the testing. And then they ran a two-and-a-half-month pilot where they put out the six total models in 52 different locations across a broad range of neighborhoods. Then they invited the public to test them out and rate them. In San Francisco, when it comes to trash cans, it's out with the old and in with the new. There is a QR code, as mentioned, that you can see on the side of these trash cans. If you have an opinion about it, go ahead and scan that QR code and give your feedback. And we saw what ones worked, what ones didn't, which ones could be broken into, if they got tagged, which ones were easy to clean, which ones were easy to service, how were they for
现成的垃圾桶型号纳入测试。然后他们进行了两个半月的试点，在各种各样的邻里街区的52个不同地点投放了总共6种型号。接着他们邀请公众进行测试并评分。在旧金山，说到垃圾桶，那就是旧的不去，新的不来。如前所述，你可以在这些垃圾桶的侧面看到一个二维码。如果你对它有什么看法，尽管去扫那个二维码并给出你的反馈。我们观察了哪些型号管用，哪些不管用，哪些容易被撬开，如果它们被涂鸦了，哪些容易清洗，哪些容易维护，它们的维护情况如何，人们对它们的感受如何？
maintenance, and what did people feel about them? So we tested them with the garbage service folks who have to empty the cans. We tested them with our own folks who have to maintain and clean them. We tested them with businesses and members of the public who have to use them to see what they liked. And then we wanted to go even a step further just to see which ones could actually be manufactured en masse. Eventually, thousands of people weighed in on the designs. And Rachel says they were mostly very thoughtful about it. I think that's one thing that makes our city endearing is that the public will weigh in on just about anything.
所以我们让必须清空垃圾桶的垃圾服务人员对它们进行了测试。我们让我们负责维护和清洁的员工对它们进行了测试。我们让必须使用它们的企业和公众成员对它们进行了测试，看看他们喜欢哪种。然后我们想更进一步，看看哪些型号实际上可以大规模生产。最终，数千人对这些设计进行了权衡和投票。雷切尔说，大家对此都非常深思熟虑。我认为这也是让我们的城市充满可爱之处的一点，那就是公众几乎对任何事情都会发表意见。
Again, there are going to be 3,000 of these out on the street. and they're going to be in every neighborhood. So people want to know, like, what's going to be in front of their home or their business or when they're walking their dog or taking their kids to school. They want to have a say in it. But there was criticism, too. Some people were like, what are you doing San Francisco Public Works? Why does the public have to weigh in on garbage cans?
再说一次，街上将会有3000个这样的垃圾桶，而且它们会出现在每一个街区。所以人们想知道，比如，放在他们家门口、店门口、或者他们遛狗、带孩子上学时的东西会是什么样的。他们希望有发言权。但也有批评的声音。有些人会问，旧金山公共工程局你们在搞什么鬼？为什么公众必须对垃圾桶指手画脚？
And then there was the cost of the prototypes. The prototype cost $20,000 per can. As one supervisor puts it, It's a Fox News headline waiting to happen. Look, you may think this is trivial, not worthy of editorial time. Well, I disagree. And sure enough, it did end up on Fox News. It's not just about trash cans.
还有原型机的成本问题。每个原型的造价高达2万美元。正如一位监事所说，这简直是为福克斯新闻准备的头条新闻。听着，你可能会认为这微不足道，不值得花时间写社论。嗯，我不同意。果不其然，它最终还是登上了福克斯新闻。这不仅仅是关于垃圾桶的问题。
It's about a city, like many others in America, that's really gone off the rails. I'm curious because there was a lot of media focus on the cost rather than the design. How did you and your colleagues actually explain to the public why those prototypes were so expensive? Yeah, so we were paying for design and development. I guess we could these days just put in AI, design me a garbage can, but we had to get industrial designers to come up with it. They had to really look at what could withstand the rigors of a public garbage can in San Francisco. And then they actually had to be manufactured, right? It's, we didn't put them on a 3D printer.
这是关于一个像美国许多其他城市一样彻底失控的城市。我很好奇，因为很多媒体都聚焦于成本而不是设计，你和你的同事究竟是如何向公众解释为什么这些原型机如此昂贵的？是的，我们当时是在为设计和研发付费。我想如今我们可能只要输入人工智能，让它帮我设计一个垃圾桶就行了，但当时我们必须找工业设计师来想办法。他们必须真正研究什么样材质的东西能够承受旧金山公共垃圾桶的严苛考验。然后它们实际上必须被制造出来，对吧？我们可不是把它们放在3D打印机里打印出来的。
We had to go and have them manufactured. So $20,000 or so a can for the prototype that's not a crazy amount of money. When you're talking about, you know, these 3,000 garbage cans that are going to last hopefully a generation. What is really interesting, though, is when we went out to bid for who can manufacture these garbage cans in mass, the price was very reasonable. It actually came a little lower than what we initially expected. So each garbage can is going to be about just under $1,400, $1,375. And if you look at off-the-shop models, it's about the same or a little bit less, actually. But the public didn't just complain about the cost of the trash cans.
我们不得不去找人把它们制造出来。所以原型机每个造价2万美元左右，这并不是一个疯狂的数字。当你谈论你知道的这3000个希望能够用上一代人的垃圾桶时。不过，真正有趣的是，当我们为谁能大规模制造这些垃圾桶进行招标时，价格非常合理。它实际上比我们最初预期的还要低一点。所以每个垃圾桶大约不到1400美元，也就是1375美元。如果你看看现成的型号，其实也差不多或者稍微便宜一点。但公众不仅抱怨垃圾桶的成本。
They also eventually complained about the amount of time the whole process was taking. This whole undertaking, the designing, prototyping, testing, and deciding which cans to go with, It all started back in 2017, and the garbage cans are still not out on the streets of San Francisco. Rachel says they should roll out this summer, which is nine years from the start. It will probably be about that long since we started talking about new garbage cans of going through. Wow. So it's been a really long process. And I think people should hit us on that a little bit, but we do have, I'm not going to make excuses, but we certainly have explanations.
他们最终还抱怨整个过程所花费的时间太长。整个行动，包括设计、制作原型、测试以及决定选择哪种垃圾桶，这一切都始于2017年，而这些垃圾桶至今还没有出现在旧金山的街道上。雷切尔说它们应该在今年夏天推出，也就是从开始算起的第九个年头。从我们开始讨论新垃圾桶并经历这个过程算起，大概也就是这么长时间了。哇。所以这是一个非常漫长的过程。我想人们确实应该为此稍微敲打我们一下，但我不会找借口，不过我们确实有解释。
contracting processes, competitive bidding, and COVID was a huge one. Everything was put on hold. People had to rethink the money we had. How was it going to be spent? Should we spend it on new garbage cans or should we go and just try to jerry-rig the old ones we have and try to keep them going as long as we can? Everything Rachel's saying is true. COVID created a real two-to-three-year time warp when everything fell apart. But take that away and you're still looking at six years.
签约流程、竞争性招标，而新冠疫情是一个巨大的因素。一切都按下了暂停键。人们不得不重新思考我们拥有的资金。这些钱将如何花？我们应该把钱花在新的垃圾桶上，还是应该去拼凑我们现有的旧垃圾桶，并尽量让它们尽可能长久地运转下去？雷切尔所说的一切都是真的。新冠疫情造成了一个长达两三年的时间扭曲期，当时一切都陷入了混乱。但抛开这个不谈，你仍然需要花上六年时间。
to get a new trash can on the street. It just seems like it should not take longer to pick a trash can than it takes to build a skyscraper. What model did the city ultimately choose? And how much did the public input affect that decision? Yeah, so a lot. So we chose the Slim Silhouette model. That was the narrow can with stainless steel bars on the outside.
才能让一个新的垃圾桶出现在街头。这给人的感觉是，挑选一个垃圾桶所花费的时间不应该比建造一座摩天大楼还要长。这座城市最终选择了哪种型号？公众的意见对这个决定有多大影响？是的，影响很大。所以我们选择了“苗条剪影”型号。那就是带有外部不锈钢栏杆的窄型垃圾桶。
The Slim Silhouette was favored by both by the maintenance folks, by the people who service the can, and then definitely by the public. It was the number one choice of the public. We had to make tweaks, though. We wanted to change the size of the opening so people could use it for their cardboard lunchboxes. We wanted to change the ribs on it on the outside exterior,
“苗条剪影”同时受到了维护人员、垃圾清理人员的青睐，当然也得到了公众的喜爱。它是公众的第一选择。不过我们必须进行调整。我们想要改变开口的尺寸，以便人们可以用它来装纸板午餐盒。我们想要改变外表面的肋条，
kind of a design element, so they're easier to clean. And then we also fiddled a little bit with a lock to make it a more hardened lock, and also easy for the garbage men and women to service it. So we're going to manufacture about a half a dozen. They're just in the process. and then the manufacturer is doing a very rigorous in-house test.
这算是一种设计元素，这样它们更容易清洗。然后我们还稍微调整了锁，使其成为一个更坚固的锁，同时也方便环卫工人们对其进行维护。所以我们要制造大约半打左右。它们目前正在生产中，然后制造商正在进行非常严格的内部测试。
So really like bang it with everything they can. I love that. A trash can tester. So many jobs you never really think about. You won't think about that. I'm curious, why do you think trash and cleanliness has become a charged issue in San Francisco? I think part of it might be political. San Francisco is a very blue city, Democratic, liberal.
所以真的是用尽他们所能的一切去猛砸。我喜欢这样。一个垃圾桶测试员。有那么多你从没真正想过的工作。你不会想到那个。我很好奇，为什么你认为垃圾和清洁问题在旧金山成了一个敏感的话题？我认为部分原因可能是政治性的。旧金山是一个非常蓝的城市，民主党，自由派。
We've had Gavin Newsom, Kamala Harris, Diane Feinstein. We've had a lot of big named Democrats come out of this city. It's nice to take a hit at it. I'll venture to say it's the most beautiful city in the country. It's one of the most beautiful cities in the world. It is not trashed everywhere. The trash in San Francisco, it's on par with a lot of other cities. The trash cans, though, like there's a constituent.
我们有加文·纽森、卡玛拉·哈里斯、黛安·范斯坦。我们这座城市走出了很多大牌民主党人。抓住这个攻击一下感觉挺好。我敢说这是全国最美丽的城市。它是世界上最美丽的城市之一。并非到处都是垃圾。旧金山的垃圾，和许多其他城市不相上下。不过垃圾桶，就像是有一个选区。
for every trash can in San Francisco. There are people who are for the trash can and people who are against the trash can. And then it's one of our jobs at Public Works to try to find the right balance with that. It strikes me that trash collection is this fundamental service that cities provide. And I think sometimes if people see piles of trash in certain parts of the city, they make a certain logical leap, which is if they, if they're not a certain logical leap, which is if the city can't get this right, it must not be working well in all these other ways. Is that your sense of the way that garbage works politically? That's certainly an interesting way to look at it.
为旧金山的每一个垃圾桶而设。有支持垃圾桶的人，也有反对垃圾桶的人。然后，尝试找到其中的平衡点就是我们公共工程部门的工作之一。这让我觉得，垃圾收集是城市提供的这项基础服务。我认为有时如果人们看到城市某些地方堆满垃圾，他们就会做出某种逻辑飞跃，那就是，如果他们，如果他们没有——某种逻辑飞跃，那就是如果城市连这个都搞不定，那么它在所有其他方面肯定也运作不好。你觉得垃圾问题在政治运作上是这样的吗？这当然是一个很有意思的看法。
I think you have a similar thing, probably in the Midwest and the East Coast where it's snow removal. Can you get the streets plowed when there's a snowstorm if you're a mayor? People look at those things. There's something called pothole politics, right? The basic things, the basic services. We are out there cleaning the streets of San Francisco literally 24 hours a day with specialized cleaning operations, everything from manual sweepers to flusher trucks and sweeper trucks to people driving around and pickup trucks, picking up litter they see. And then we have about 120 now folks who are called block sweepers who are in commercial corridors who literally are with a broom and dustpan sweeping up the corridor. So we are going to schools, talking to kids as young as second graders.
我想你可能会在中西部和东海岸遇到类似的情况，那就是清除积雪。如果你是个市长，下暴雪时你能把街道上的雪铲干净吗？人们会关注这些事情。有一种东西叫坑洼政治，对吧？基本的事情，基本的服务。我们实际上每天24小时都在用专门的清洁作业清理旧金山的街道，从人工清扫车到冲洗车和清扫车，再到人们开着皮卡车四处转悠，捡起他们看到的垃圾。然后我们现在大约有120名被称为街区清扫员的人，他们在商业走廊里，拿着扫帚和簸箕清扫走廊。所以我们要去学校，和最小到二年级的孩子们交流。
like when you said, like, how do this end up in my living room? Think about if you have something you want to get rid of, what's the proper way to get rid of it. It's like ultimately you can bring people to trash cans, but you cannot make them throw away their trash. So really, there's an underlying behavioral issue that you've been talking about throughout this interview. There is. It really is if people did the right thing, right? You have garbage, where are you going to put it, that it's not going to affect the common areas and really the public good. People don't want to see trash on their streets. People don't feel good about that.
就像你说的，这东西怎么最后到了我的客厅里？想想如果你有什么东西想扔掉，正确的扔掉方式是什么。最终你可以把人带到垃圾桶前，但你不能强迫他们扔掉垃圾。所以实际上，你在这篇采访中一直在谈论的是一个潜在的行为问题。确实如此。这真的是如果人们做了正确的事，对吧？你有垃圾，你要把它放在哪里，才不会影响公共区域和真正的公共利益。人们不想在街上看到垃圾。人们对此感觉不好。
There are a lot of reasons why you don't want trash on the street. But a big one is how do you feel about your city and about your neighborhood if you see litter around? The new cans are finally rolling out this summer, and honestly, they look great. They're so sleek. But as Rachel has made clear, you can do. design the perfect trash can and still have dirty streets. Litter in San Francisco isn't just a design problem. It's a complex behavioral problem caused by people dumping household garbage to dodge collection fees and rummaging through bins because they have nowhere else to go and illegally dumping,
你不想让街上满是垃圾有很多原因。但其中一个主要原因，如果你看到周围有垃圾，你对自己的城市和社区有什么感觉？新垃圾桶终于在今年夏天陆续推出了，老实说，它们看起来棒极了。它们太流线型了。但正如雷切尔所说的那样清楚，你可以设计出完美的垃圾桶，但仍然会有肮脏的街道。旧金山的垃圾不仅是一个设计问题。这是一个复杂的行为问题，由人们倾倒生活垃圾以逃避收集费用，以及由于无处可去而在垃圾桶里翻找并进行非法倾倒所引起的，
I'm going to say this number again, 18,000 tons of garbage on the streets a year. A better trash can is definitely a tool, and I'm sure it will help. But it's not going to fix it all. We started this episode with a question. Who determines the trash cans? Even how they get picked up, how are they maintained, how are they designed? And we have a pretty good answer, at least for the nearly 3,000 trash cans on the city's sidewalks. They are overseen by San Francisco Public Works. The department installs, maintains, and repairs the trash cans. They prioritize. They prioritize placing cans in the busiest places, like in commercial areas and plazas and near bus stops and other areas with a lot of foot traffic. When it comes to putting out new trash cans, they take
我要再说一遍这个数字，每年街上有18,000吨垃圾。一个更好的垃圾桶绝对是一个工具，我相信它会有所帮助。但它无法解决所有问题。我们以一个问题开始了这一集。谁来决定垃圾桶？甚至它们是如何被收集的，如何维护的，如何设计的？我们有了一个相当不错的答案，至少对于市内人行道上近3,000个垃圾桶来说是这样。它们由旧金山公共工程局监管。该部门安装、维护和修理垃圾桶。他们设定优先级。他们优先将垃圾桶放在最繁忙的地方，比如商业区、广场、公交车站附近以及其他行人较多的地方。在推出新的垃圾桶时，他们会采取
feedback from the public via 311 and requests from the board of supervisors. Sometimes they'll run pilot programs to see how more or differently designed trash cans might affect litter in a given area. So if you're ever wondering why it takes San Francisco a decade and half a million dollars to choose a trash can, now you know. Consider this service request resolved. Today on the show, you heard Roman Mars, no further introduction needed, and you also heard Rachel Gordon, the director of policy and communications at San Francisco Public Works. Do you have a question about infrastructure that's been bugging you. Maybe it's something you walk past
通过311收集公众反馈，并接受监事会的请求。有时他们会进行试点项目，看看设计更好或不同的垃圾桶可能会如何影响特定区域的垃圾情况。所以，如果你曾经想过为什么旧金山需要十年时间和五十万美元来选择一个垃圾桶，现在你知道了。认为此服务请求已解决。今天在节目中，你听到了罗曼·马斯，无需多做介绍，你还听到了雷切尔·戈登，旧金山公共工程局政策与传播总监。你有没有一个一直困扰你的关于基础设施的问题。也许这是你走过时
without really thinking about it, like a fire hydrant or a parking meter or a manhole cover. If there's a piece of infrastructure you've always wondered about, we want to hear from you. Send us your service requests
并没有真正去思考的事情，比如消防栓、停车收费表或人孔盖。如果你一直对某个基础设施感到好奇，我们想听听你的意见。发送你的服务请求
by recording a voice memo with your question and emailing it to service request at 99PI.org. And remember, if you litter, a city worker like Rachel might be secretly watching
通过录制带有你问题的语音备忘录并将其发送至 servicerequest@99PI.org。记住，如果你乱扔垃圾，像雷切尔这样的城市工作者可能在暗中看着
and judging you. I'm Delaney Hall. Infrastructure is everywhere, and we're here to help you decode it. Service request is a production of 99% Invisible and Campside Media. The show is produced and fact-checked by Julia Case Levine and edited by Shoshi Shmulevitz. Mix by Iwin Lai Trimuan. Theme song and music by Swan Rayal. Additional editing by Emmett Fitzgerald and Vivian Lay.
并评判你。我是德兰尼·霍尔。基础设施无处不在，我们在这里帮助你解读它。Service request 是 99% Invisible 和 Campside Media 的出品。该节目由朱莉娅·凯斯·莱文制作和核实事实，由肖希·什穆莱维茨剪辑。混音由艾温·赖·特里穆恩完成。主题曲和音乐由斯旺·拉亚尔创作。埃姆费尔德和维维安·莱提供额外剪辑。
Show arts by Aaron Nestor. Special thanks this week to Roman Mars, who's our boss at 99, P.CAPE 2 is 99PI's executive producer. Matt Scher is the executive producer at Campside. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our Discord server. There's a link to that and every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
节目插图由亚伦·内斯特制作。本周特别感谢罗曼·马斯，他是我们在 99 的老板，CAPE 2 是 99PI 的执行制片人。马特·谢尔是 Campside 的执行制片人。我们是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一员。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站上找到我们，以及我们的 Discord 服务器。在 99PI.org 上有一个指向该链接以及 99PI 过去每一集的链接。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。